nous allons rêver un petit peu oubli la
grisaille le froid également avec vous
maons bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes donc la
finaliste de ce concours l'une des
finalistes vous êtes en tout 18
puisqu'il y a plusieurs postes à
pourvoir 6 ils ne sont plus que trois
trois c'est d'ailleurs le chiffre de
cette édition trois finalistes dans la
catégorie avancturier de l'otbach c'est
le territoire nord de l'Australie on
disait en tout 18 finalistes 600000
candidature au départ comment vous avez
fait pour arriver parmi les finalistes
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence faut
croire que je suis me démarqué je pense
que j'ai fait eu à la base c'était la
sélection sur une vidéo donc je pense
que mon l'originalité de ma vidéo a
séduit et puis ensuite c'était toute une
campagne de communication d'être dans
les médias et je pense que j'ai su me
démarquer en en montrant que j'étais
motivé et en apparaissant un peu partout
alors pourquoi avoir tenté déjà aussi au
tout début cette aventure j'avais déjà
l'envie d'aller en Australie j'avais
prévu de faire un visa vacan travail
là-bas et donc quand j'ai entendu à la
radio le message sur le concours best
job in the world j'ai tout de suite
postulé puisque c'était un c'est ils
vendent vraiment du rêve un poste à
100000 dollars en Australie pour 6 Mo
c'est pour une période de 6 mois ça
commencerait vers le milieu du mois
d'août ouais et ça consisterait en quoi
donc il y a plusieurs postes on le
disait he ces catégories sur le la
partie nord du du pays ça cons voilà moi
c'est le job d'aventurier dans l'outbag
donc c'est un peu aller vivre des
aventures Jol sur oui c'est très bien
c'est original et euh par exemple dans
le l'intitulé du job c'est aller faire
faire des tours en montolfière au-dessus
de de l'Outback faire des randonnées
dormir à la belle étoile et le job c'est
surtout ensuite de montrer tout ça sur
des blogs sur les réseaux sociaux
promouvoir l'Australie et le vis vacan
travail en Australie et pourquoi
l'Australie vous fait autant rêver j'is
passé 3 semaines en Australie en 2009
juste avant de faire un vis à vacan
travail en Nouvelle-Zélande et je
m'étais dit je reviendrai parce que
j'avais trouvé ça magnifique et puis vu
l'immensité du territoire je pense que
un an c'est pas c'est un minimum pour
pour visiter l'Australie on voit
quelques images du pays juste justement
que vous allez en tout cas découvrir
déjà parce que même si vous n'êtes pas
retenu pour le pour le poste il y aura
une audition la suite c'est un c'est un
entretien et vous allez bientôt partir
pour aller passer cet entretien en
Australie tout ferit payer il vous paye
le voyage en plus c'est déjà c'est déjà
ça de gagner parce que je comptais
partir donc là c'est vrai que je suis
invité par l'Office du Tourisme
australien on va vivre à mon avis une
super semaine essayer plein de choses
tous ensemble on sera les 18 au départ
d'Australie le 12 juin à Sydney et
ensuite chaque groupe de 3 pour son job
défini va quitter le quitter Sydney pour
aller dans son territoire donc moi je
serai avec mes deux concurrents dans
laback à partir du du 15 juin les jobs
qui font rêver meilleur métier du du
monde tout simplement c'est l'Austral
qui propose cette opération afin de de
séduire de faire venir de de nouveaux
talents pour pour le pays on va regarder
le spot que vous avez mentionné tout à
l'heure c'est le le petit spot qui a
fait sans doute la différence c'est le
votre dossier de candidature votre carte
de visite on le
regarde
Advent frch journalist and phpher TR
she's horider Sky tramper and more she
work as a beer
AER in more than countries
and un spot dynamique voilà on avait pas
le choix 30 secondes c'était très concis
donc fallait il fallait dynamique j'ai
retourné les scènes justement plusieurs
fois pour paraître vraiment super
dynamique donc ça a marché apparent et
quand on regarde ce spot justement on
voit que vous êtes effectivement la la
fille de la situation puisque vous avez
beaucoup voyagé par le passé oui ou oui
j'ai visité plus d'une vingtaine de pays
et vraiment c'est ma passion voyage la
photographie le journalisme aussi donc
là ce métier c'est vraiment un job de R
pour moi ça réunit tout ce que j'aime là
vous êtes entre monte- laajolie Paris
vous sentez allé trroit sur ce territo
toi ben oui c'est vrai que ça fait 3 ans
que je suis en France c'était chouette
de retrouver ma famille mes amis mais
j'ai envie de partir ça fait ça fait un
peu long en France donc j'ai envie
d'aller voir ailleurs vous avez
mentionné cette vingtaine de pays on
peut peut-être regarder votre parcours
master à Oxford en Angleterre ensuite
c'était un poste de chargé de mission
oui au bureau du livre à l'ambassade de
France en Roumanie et puis ensuite c'est
là que j'ai fait mon visa vacances
travail en Nouvelle-Zélande pendant 8
mois où j'ai conduit un van que j'avais
acheté sur 16000 km pour faire le tour
des îles je suis rentrée en France où là
j'ai repris j'ai fait travailler en tant
que journaliste en tant que Chargé des
Relations Publiques et puis dans une
association de libraire internationale
où je viens de finir de travailler pour
pouvoir partir en Australie pour partir
en Australie et donc passer ces ces
dernières ligne droite les derniers
entretiens pour décrocher on vous le
souhaite ce meilleur land ces six
meilleurs jobs du monde qui est proposé
par l'Office de Tourisme d'Australie
pourquoi cette envie de de voyage aussi
parce que en France c'est quoi c'est
compliqué c'est morose aussi le contexte
économique oui c'est sûr que surtout
dans mon domaine je suis dans le domaine
culturel du livre il y a pas énormément
d'opportunités et je me suis dit que en
allant en Australie peut-être que
j'aurais des portes ouvertes et puis
même dans d'autres domaines c'est vrai
que c'est difficile aussi en France
quand on est dans un tel domaine de
ensuite changer de voie et je me suis
dit que là je pouvais expérimenter
d'autres Jobs donc pourquoi pas me
reconvertir en agent touristique
représentant l'Australie dans le monde
entier ce sera super quand on regarde
aussi votre CV vous avez fait plein
plein de boulot AZ fait plein plein de
choses des potagers ton de la plous
travailler dans les motels vous avez
tout fait oui ça c'était pas mal en
Nouvelle-Zélande en fait mon projet
c'était de d'aller travailler chez les
gens et du coup j'ai fait plein de
petits jobs comme ça j'étais chez des
chercheurs d'or j'étais chez des
apiculteurs j'ai travaillé en tant que
fermière aller mener les troupeaux donc
c'est vrai que j'ai fait pas mal de
choses et je compte bien faire pareil en
Australie aller vivre de nouvelles
expériences donc vous allez partir pour
l'Australie passer ces entretiens ces
entretiens vous les imaginez comment
comment ça va se dérouler ce sera un
entretien très strict très carré il y
aura des tests physiques ils vous ont
donné des indications non pas trop ils
son reste assez vague là-dessus je pense
qu'on va passer devant un jury de façon
très officielle et puis ils vont nous
suivre à mon avis on va faire des des
épreuves mais pas pas tant épreuv que ça
on va faire des des attractions
touristiques des activités à mon avis il
vont nous observer voir comment on
réagit en groupe les équipes de
communication et du marketing je pense
qu'ils vont pas mal nous suivre et
décider en fonction de notre
personnalité et nous suiv vraiment oui
tout au long de la semaine à mon avis
c'est surtout ça essayer de d'écrire des
des blogs aussi puisque ce sera le
métier une fois qu'on sera sur place de
de bloguer d'écrire de communiquer donc
ils vont ils vont vérifier toutes ses
compétences il va falloir t aussi de
votre motivation votre engagement tout à
l'heure vous faisiez quelques photos sur
ce plateau avant que l'émission commence
ça va vous servir pour montrer qu'on a
aussi parlé relayé en France beaucoup
dans les différents médias votre votre
envie de partir oui exactement c'est ce
qui demandait en fait l' fice du
tourisme australien pour être dans les
finalistes il fallait montrer qu'on
avait su faire parler de nous qu'on
avait pu communiquer avec les médias
qu'on savait se servir des réseaux
sociaux notamment des blogs puisque
comme ce sera le métier ils veulent
vraiment voir tester nos compétences en
direct donc c'est pour ça que là il faut
que je blogue tout ce que je fais il
faut que je poste ensuite sur votre
Facebook si jamais ils ont envie d'en
savoir plus ils verront qu'il y a aussi
plu qui vous a soutenuou ex j'ai eu un
dessin de Plantu une super vidéo de
Denis Brognard donc j'ai plusieurs très
grands parins et ça c'est ça je pense
que ça aussi compé j'aimerais profiter
aussi de votre présence pour aborder
peut-être un autre sujet j'en parlais
dans les titres tout à l'heure
l'enseignement en anglais des cours à
l'université par exemple ça fait débat
en France les amateurs de la langue
française de la Francophonie s'y oppose
malgré de viv protestation le le texte à
tout de même est en voie d'être adopté à
l'Assemblée vous qui voyagez beaucoup
qui êtes jeune les cours en anglais à
l'université ça vous semble normal j'im
ah oui moi j'aurais bien aimé avoir des
cours en anglais autres que les cours
d'anglais parce que c'est vrai qu'en
France souvent même quand on a des cours
d'anglais les professeurs parlent en
français ce qui est pas très logique et
du coup le niveau est pas est vraiment
pas terrible les Français sont connus
pour pas avoir un super niveau d'anglais
donc oui pour moi c'estimage que vousz
c'est l'image que vous aviez lorsque
vous arriviez dans un autre pays euh oui
donc j'essayé de de faire des efforts
mais c'est vrai je suis française mais
je sais parler anglais oui voilà c'est
ça c'est vrai qu'on a réputation de pas
très bien parler l'anglais d'être assez
autocentré donc c'est pas plus mal